let's go instead to our caller from the
3:07 area code who's calling today from
3:07 can you hear me yes I can I like
about establishment Democrats okay so
like why are established and Democrats
like that like because I you know I know
many different Democrats are against
with stuff like Medicare for all and
free college but why well what you have
to understand is that a centrist
Democrat is very similar to a centrist
Republican and in fact in a lot of
countries centrist Democrats would
probably be part of a moderate
right-wing party more than they would a
moderate left-wing party particularly in
countries that have an actual
progressive party so moderate centrist
Democrats want to basically perpetuate
the same status quo that we have in
terms of the relationship between the
centers of power corporations the elites
etc they are funded by a lot of the same
interests so it's basically like
different wrapping of very similar
underlying products that's why they end
up being very similar to Republicans
because they are in most ways yeah do
you think like the are establishment
Democrats I like people to even recall
us or theirs and they're just like so
crap they don't work they don't okay I
mean you're trying to guess what's or
people's heads right you're trying to
get you it's in the same way that it's
possible that a centrist Democrat could
publicly say I'm not for free college
but like privately before it you could
also have someone who is more
progressive in their public facing side
that says they are for free college but
aren't really for it but they know it's
not likely to happen so they just say
that I mean you there's always people
who are saying things because they're
trying to build up their public persona
in a certain way and they're not being
genuine I don't think it's really
important to dwell on that because
ultimately you're trying to read what's
in people's minds what matters is what
they do and say publicly because that's
what ultimately gets things done
yeah I understand that but I'm from
Wyoming like we don't like whatever
Democrats alike like they mean in
Wyoming like a lot of our Democrats can
be like more progressive but we don't
have a lot of stablishment Democrat
interesting that surprises me
yeah because we we supported a talk and
we caucus and we voted for Bernie and
we're gonna do that again
2020 I know I know they're like more
thousand Democrats and like the
Northeast do you think I don't you know
they're so there's a cut there's a
problem with that analysis so for
example in Massachusetts you have a lot
of like Kennedy style old-school
Democrats and then you've got
progressives in other parts of the
country the more centrist Democrats are
not really Kennedy style Democrats there
are more Blue Dog Democrats that are
often more socially conservative so I
think that you have centrist Democrats
all over the country and they're
different in different parts of the
country in the Northeast they're more
kind of like old money Kennedy type
Democrats in the South I've got the Blue
Dogs in Wyoming I don't know what you
have it sounds like you've got a mix of
different things but I think you've got
to look at it in a little more detail I
appreciate the call thank you so much
really great to hear from you